ich kam ich sah ich wurde besiegt meine
oma die mir gesagt
zu jedem topf gibt es einen deckel und
meinen deckel dann habe ich in der
schweiz gefunden ich kann mir nicht
vorstellen dass es dieses exemplar noch
ein zweites mal gibt
[Musik]
bislang ist
liebe fragt nicht nach dem pass liebe
kann grenzenlos sein
liebe nimmt uns an der hand und schon
sind wir hin und weg das sind schweizer
liebesgeschichten aus aller welt ein
großer hof südschweden dauern heißt anja
zimmermann weg der liebe zum karl trat
mit jack verschlagen
vor der schweiz schweden von der
automechanikerin zur büring
dort lebt sie mit ihrem sohn max unter 5
und 7
von anja hätte kaum mit der schweiz
viele moore kam und was wir jetzt noch
acht jahre mit anja was sie steht die
schweiz
was ist typisch schweizerisch was ich
eigentlich überhaupt sind die
schweizerisch also ein schweizerisches
wort was ich habe lernen können ins
leben das ist überhaupt nicht
also ich weiß nicht was typisch schweiz
wahrscheinlich also sie versucht auch
nicht weil die schweizer nicht zu
sprechen
wir sprechen hochdeutsch sie haben ja
schon auf gesagt jetzt sprechen war mehr
schweizerdeutsch mit uns was sie hat
eine mutter besser verstehen wenn die
stimmt wieso kommt aber das mag sie
nicht
anders als in der schweiz hetzt
schwedenplatz viel platz anja und
bewirtschaftet das riesige gebiet mit
wald wiesen und sogar einen kreativen
andere weit liebe
auf geht's weiter laufen los
[Musik]
was jetzt
ab
ich merke schnell dort zwei und live
strick
[Musik]
das muss sie auch darauf eingehen wie
anja das und sagen anbringt deswegen ist
das thema
die situation beruhigte sich dann
ziemlich schnell wenn wir da nicht nur
vorgibt wichtigste cloud sich frei
riemsloh gilt nur für binationale bei
tanja ihre liebschaft für dritte
unterstützt auto kaum den platz hier
also denn dir dass du gemacht oder für
anja der platz forscher fordern ja da
aber hat die post hättest du dir das
vorstellen können mit einer frau
zusammen zu sein die weder reich noch
sich für tiere interessiert manchmal
will ja auch zeit verbringe mit seinem
partner und wenn man da nichts
gemeinsame interesse hat damals grüne
hat die sowieso schon sehr viel zeit in
anspruch nehmen dann wird es natürlich
schwierig was sieht man sich einfach
sitzen
[Musik]
wir haben unsere geschichte in zürich
angefangen ja aus wir kennen gelernt
habe habe war ich ein praktikant in eine
restaurant wurde petrus im wallis
syriens uhr katalog ali annika das schon
bald hin und weg wie viel genau da
draußen so gestanden da hat stil und
guest natürlich und gastraum gesucht ich
bin die stadt wie immer verloren da habe
ich sie da einfach gesehen ist sie da
gleichheit hat mit dem geld und zu
wissen dass ich einfach jene system
praktisch gesehen zehn stunden
dies wird jetzt erkenne keine illegal
ich weiß schon mit gestern ihre pistole
und den habe ich eigentlich nicht anders
können machen und über auf dem holt den
dixie und an der konkreten wartet bis
sie fertig ist
es ist einfach herrlich fordert rief er
ich weiß nicht was passiert dabei weiß
jeder zeit passieren und mich
geschäftlich republik und vor allem den
vorsitz ich denn wirklich die ganze zeit
über und den 75 herausgeholt und
bespitzelte herrschen kann ich sie dir
und du weißt nicht wie lange sie dass
ihr weg ist oder ob sie sogar wird
schaffen in so einer anderen ausgang ich
ganze land zieht sie auf der bank
jeanette erinnere sich allerdings erst
sehr schädlich weniger romantisch krump
[Musik]
nach meiner arbeit kaum eltern er ich
war ein bisschen schockiert
warum ein mann hat mir auf mir vor der
thüringer orten hat es ist zum glück
wird sie glauben
züchter sogar direkte draht will ich
finde er hat mich gefragt ob ihr etwas
trinken könne man dann ich habe gesagt
ja aber wir kennen uns nicht gesehen
muss ich ja kein wille jedes gespann
geworden dann sind vielleicht ja auch
eine kurzversion als ob sie ob sie eine
telefonnummer oder so wahrscheinlich
besser ist oder so und da ich habe auch
nein gesagt und dann aber am schluss
habe ich meine sky geben sich zum glück
richtig sie und ich wäre dann einfach
ziemlich lange im beruf skype schreibe
zwei wochen später habe ich meine skype
ein gebirge und ich habe sehr viel
erzählt von ihnen gepflegt
ja ich habe entschieden insel antworten
und dann wir haben gesprochen
es war nicht so schlimm es sympathisch
aus wo wir haben viel geredet und dann
ich erinnere mich daran dass er hatte
schöne augen
ja sie mich jetzt auch nein ich habe mit
einer angefangen mit mit webcam und in
[Musik]
vier mal auf eine webcam sind sagt beide
sehr sympathisch city webcams dass ich
das hier ist ganz ganz teufel
nachgegangen und dann einfach denn hat
es wieder mal zu wiederholen sein herz
ist eine software die über kleins zehn
user der petrucci reitern des bahnstroms
in überwinde remove buchens gemeinsames
leben
das fahrrad soll becker vor
jetzt trainiere ich muss mich gestorben
und irgendwie ist das sowieso sexy für
mich dass ich einfach gesagt jetzt muss
ich wenn ich normal aber dann muss sie
jetzt aber ich kann deine geschichte
irgendwie wir einfach nur kind glaubt es
geschafft glaubt für das ich selber habe
immer geglaubt dass ich so haben einfach
so vor mich hin vegetiert
sarah hat alle kraft hat ihren ehemann
und die beiden erwachsenen in verlag und
ist mit dröhnt und zwei fini wonik im
thurgau chocolate erste mal sieht vor 20
jahren wieder ganz auf sich allein
gestellt und noch diesmal hat sich spürt
das level 50 bis anderen die partei für
sie
[Musik]
also 18 jahre tierarten ist dann
irgendwann nimmt ein wunder
bis der user so läuft ein wenig freunde
ja ich muss mal online tätigen kwanika
so viel neugierde hat sich dann
irgendwann und ich hatte er
mitgeschrieben und eigentlich
wahrscheinlich zu fall
ich bin da ich ja gar nicht irgendwie
mich im ausland wählen morgen und und er
eigentlich einen britischen der schweiz
die feuerwerks- und hatte glück gehabt
und hat mich gefunden ja denken und erst
die familien am besten verhindert us
import beschuss wieder einfach sexy
schnitt eine künstlich nicht verstellt
einfach eine rede über gott und die welt
über ihre zara und milan gajic mit dem
ziel möglichst schnell zeimetz leibe
vermutlich hätte sich sarah dewitt neues
rennen ohne die radikale veränderung wo
sie vorher durchgemacht hat tokio der
marken operation dazu mich selber
komplett verändert angefangen mit
gewichtsverlust 50 kilo angefangen mit
teil wo wachsen die khk
ja
es ist eigentlich ziemlich schnell
geburtstag 2015 sagte ich hab ich glaube
wieder
erst gab mir extrem gut ich bin einfach
zufrieden
[Musik]
neue mensch sexy wurde vor vitalität und
lebensfreude für zara ist es - mundo
[Musik]
ich hoffe dass es nur freunde gibt und
es ist logisch dass das bild das ich bis
bruch oder sich auch einfach ja
[Musik]
[Applaus]
spürt dass das falsch war sondern als
familie meine familie wird europa in dem
sinn
[Musik]
[Applaus]
der bernhard herzig drescher verloren
ihre heimat
die zwei sich entschieden dass sie
arbeiten notwendig um die der schweiz
als journalist und sportler im
diplomatischen dienst hat sich der
berner das cool können ihre rechte und
so pendelt ihr beide sind 50 jahre
zwischen zwei kulturen die nach der
hochzeit ist 19 und 27
am 10 november
[Musik]
sie hat die ddr in die archive der
assistent an der uni wenn ich hab
gewusst dass wenn ich ein zweites kind
hat dann muss ich musste mich nicht im
verborgenen statt diplomatische zählt
die tabelle hat sehr weh aber ich hab'
gefunden
wenn ich kann ich muss nur busse und
wirklich großen katholische war ließ sie
aus dem hinduistischen mumbai darstellt
so irgendwann die gretchen frage nach
der religion
spätestens wenn es hin kommt rascher und
der bayern art sind sie schnell einig
sie für mich ist es überhaupt kein fragt
sie dass sich rechtlich wird und dass
sie
dass sie nicht richtig war weil ich auch
eine christliche schule aufgewachsen und
ich habe sehr viel hat der gis und
ließen sich das problem dass ich ihm
auch eine eigenständige unabhängige frau
ob sie im kurs macht wer 50 orten ich
unternahm dimona so gern hat muss es
richtig macht aber sie ist vollkommen
dialog joint hatten als wir sie nicht
vor so zusammengewachsen ansichten sind
individuelle manchen die andere
das super
[Musik]
ja ich habe mich leben in der schweiz
also oft gar nicht so einfach nicht
aufgehört eigentlich bei uns zugeht
zeigen aber oft nicht
man habe nicht auf wir müssen wir beide
haben unser leben bereichern
los geht's
[Musik]
ich bin wieder anja m kraul und im clean
maxx schweden wir sind unterwegs zu der
ältere von crown programm zieht
sie sind uns wanderung wurde kaum 18x
sind mit ihm in das land wo sie vorher
nur auf der fähre kentert
[Musik]
so hat sie ihren einzigen sohn jean sind
traum vom eigenen betrieb vor eigenem
land und wahl zu führen
die spots deutschland finanziell
unmöglich
[Musik]
so hereinspaziert hallo ich bin mutter
freut mich sehr denn wäre jetzt genau
geortet in die branche
am kreisel er dreht nämlich eine
originelle geschäftsidee k sie sind
unter blasse hersteller zertifizierte
hof laufen musste mir ist von hof von
tanja aber ich habe vorhin schon kurz
erzählt mein berufsleben so viele neue
sachen gemacht
so macht man halt wieder was neues nicht
so schlimm da stillstand ist rückschritt
nicht
das kann man sagen unsere existenz war
eigentlich sehr stabil in deutsch in
deutschland das hat mich ja so
verwundert was ist das für ein vater der
nur weil sein sohn quasi diesen großen
traum hat in schweden ein hof kauft und
sagt hier kannst du deinen traum
verwirklichen hat das auch ein bisschen
damit zu tun dass sie ihren eigenen
traum selber vor zwar zu werden
vielleicht nicht verwirklichen konnten
eventuell virtuell dass das eben ja
schon ein familientraum war sozusagen
was das eigentlich die oma und opa noch
ein bisschen spannend dafür mag es jetzt
seit sie die als produktion haben
vielleicht konnte er noch gerne zu uns
wobei ja schon sehr gern zu uns kommt
muss man sagen ist weil es gibt immer
irgendetwas zu entdecken und zu sehen
und so weiter nicht also
dmax im glück und die raubold wie sie
jetzt anzeigen
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
aus schlechten job hat mir den übrigen
den bau des super wenn man dann auf den
türen zum ausschlägen bekommt
ich verstehe das ist anja für das leben
entschieden hat mit ihrem bekannten der
oper neben ihrem trauma offensichtlich
goldrichtig sie
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
also er ist sensationell und irgendwie
die energie für mich wirklich strom
machen und ich war froh und ich weiß
noch genau zu prüfen
und hey und ich glaube alle spieler
nervös sie aussehen und unternehmen ist
ein richtig griffig
[Musik]
[Applaus]
der erste blick nöten august sieht doris
hoffe ich schaffe posiere kürzung trifft
dort von re fitness bloggerin
bleibt noch mal machen und daher so
wunderschöne aussicht irgendwo mir dass
er mich eigentlich architekt für
tourismus er der fotograf machen
nein ich liebe sie natürlich aber
manchmal ich das ein bisschen nervig nur
ein bisschen
bequem und doris einzig via facebook
kennengelernt
natürlich hält ihres äußeren ac a a aber
das tor mäßigung von anfang märz
von außen betrachtet könnte man meinen
es sei ein wenig hochnäsig aber im
gegenteil vieles liebenswert kümmert
sich um alle stellt andere an die erste
stelle
ich liebe das
doris präsentiert sich und ihren körper
täglich riesige fans und wir sind uns
unsere beziehung sehr sicherer
dieses vertrauen ist keine eifersucht zu
und ich bin sowieso kein eifersüchtiger
mensch kurzum business david beckham
trainiertes auto hinter laut spuren gibt
mir die graue haare
[Musik]
doris hoferin bestimmt viel ihres muss
sehen dass alice ich habe 20 jahre gehe
und das volk doris ist mutter von zwei
sind noch der zweite schwangerschaft die
ihren körper die letztlich wohl sagt
eugen wir besprüht oder aber für meter
brust operation und aber darf momentan
ist probiert und so
und die hat es nacheinander mache ihr
chris kaman ist groß es geht
follower fans mit frage und ich sage
ihnen ganz klug das ist nicht überall
meter schlauch oder zum beispiel junge
frau immer noch hinterher wird eine
mögliche hätte zu erhalten
aber wenn er froh so wie immer hat er
verstanden oder sogar bei der
flüchtlinge texte verstehen
[Applaus]
das irgendwie familie war lecker
das ist international vor gut zwei
jahren storys von der spitze der charts
gelandet
2006 ist er unterwegs und sie hängt es
hochsitz wie aus dem bilderbuch queren
der diplomierte pr fachfrau coney island
woche sprach etwas macht über leichte
wie ich zum beispiel mit dem northeimer
schaffen oder und das ist irgendwie ist
das problematisch
es ist einfach immer umgangen wie
hundehaufen logodesign irgendwie
filme gemacht und die haben wir nicht
einmal ihre ganze leben in der schweiz
hat sich im ausgang blieb zusammen und
ja das ist liebe unter den menschen in
tansania gemacht und ja immerhin hat das
will ich nicht
beispiel bitter enttäuscht war dass sie
wahnsinnig bosse und dass sie im kern
für die und achtung
[Musik]
am flughafen zürich route durch den
moment sarah zellweger anklam und der
milan serbien durch
[Musik]
ohne treffer blieben immerhin noch 1
boss aber das migrationsamt
stark ein
ja
endlich schöne zäme läbe 30 ihres ziel
in den nächsten vier wochen wartet es
rechts programm
und dann
da
manager alex terry a
mancher organisieren
sarah und dem iran stünden ganz am
anfang für ihre geschichte fortsetzung
gefunkt
hin und weg auf die suche nach menschen
ausgewandert sind herzlich auf georg
eher verschlanken klar offside auf
tiflis sieht hauptstadt vor dem flieger
land am rand von crassus da wohnen
brigit und der wache viel weiß in
externe 2 ihren erfahrungen adresse
was ist an dieser mine cruisen und lüthi
geht sarah chang
a
es war traurig
hallo
auch heuer ist stärkere geschlecht ein
herr richter natürlich einfacher sind so
ist super
monat begehrlichkeit werne wache sehr
freut
schön euch zu sehen danke auch immer
also was machst du café türkische kaffee
ja ja ja gern trotzdem zu verpflichten
zumal man sich statisch und du wirst ja
ja auch denkst du auch wirklich und ich
ja ich trinke nur durch gewinnen wenn
die bibliothek und was ist das jetzt die
beste lobby wird irgendwann einfach nur
gefunden
nach einem imbiss wird und der kunde und
haben so viele fans und das hat mir eine
sehr sofort fasziniert entscheiden wer
wirklich nicht was was georges pretre
herzen landschaft
ja das hat mir auch stehen
[Musik]
man fühlt sich als schweizer sehr sehr
schlecht gegenüber seinem partner weil
in was für ein land das so unwillkommen
ist holst du sie
peter und jeanette händler von für ihre
beziehung alles andere also bilder durch
schweiz kennengelernt
zum grüne zweimal aber ein sie ein
richtiges spiel live dabei ist ein
absolvieren
also heinz beschlossen dass sich hier
ortet zuerst einmal auf dem standesamt
im wallis auf der einen seite war ich
sehr glücklich weil ich wusste jetzt
können wir endlich offiziell zusammen
sein
auf der anderen seite es war ein sehr
trauriger tag wir mussten das so
organisieren damit wir dass das hätte
sie schon wieder weg gehen müssen und
ihre familie konnte nicht da sein und
das ist das was ich einfach nicht weiß
ich getan habe viel ein
meine hochzeit das war meine haag
sie hat geweint aber nicht aus freude
sondern weil sie alle halt vermisst hat
deshalb bin ich jetzt umso glücklicher
war damit letztendlich eine richtige auf
seite
richtig böse malaysische hochzeit mit
allem drum und dran traum den sich die
beide romantiker band erfüllen
[Musik]
ein anderer traum vom eigenen hotel
nämlich platzt schwierigkeiten auch
mieter herkunft von ca zusätzlich hatten
wir dann in viele probleme mit mit mit
leuten die halt nicht offen sind
teilweise vom ort teilweise aber auch
von von von hotelgästen die es nicht
akzeptieren konnten in wie jetzt an der
rezeption von einer asiatin tipps
entgegen zu nehmen weil ihnen das
einfach nicht ins bild passt das ist
halt schon sehr sehr schlimm und für sie
schlimmer als für mich aber selbst für
mich war das schlimm weil ich sehe wie
sie leidet und dann dass es nicht gut
und dann geht es mir auch nicht so gut
ich fühle mich wohl in saas fee
ich wollte immer noch weggehen
ich wollte immer nur nach malaysia reise
heimisch werden in der schweiz für
jeanette ist schwierig sie kohl fällen
tiere schließlich sauber team eine
schöne hotel am genfersee und ihren
willen mit allen mittel für straßen
etwas zu machen damit ich mich
integrieren könnte zb habe
ich habe und jetzt lerne ich französisch
und ich esse von punkten
ich habe auch skifahren gelernt
[Musik]
am woche und ich glaube dass das ist
symmetrie woche zum ersten mal aber dass
ich ca
der mensch gesetz mir das wasser erfasst
und das ist für mich das sehr schön wird
sehr viel losglück das ist mit honig
keine gelernt einsicht kredit und der
wachau jury immer graffy der schweiz
geschaffen
warum ich habe gespürt dass ich bin ein
bisschen alt geworden und dass ich wie
mein vater sehen
ich habe bisher in angst gehabt dass
etwas passiert mit papillon dann kann
ich nämlich sehr und das ganze leben
lang also ich um mein vater wir sind wie
katz und maus gewesen riemer streit
gehabt haben und freunde sind wir
geworden nur als ich so im ausland war
schon weil der telefon
haben wir aus einer koppel gefühlt das
ist immer das ist das wichtige thema ok
meinem nächsten gestellt
aber wichtig ist dass der woche immer
docs ist die familie auf mich vorfall
sehr unkompliziert und sehr lieb
aufgehellt vor der schweiz auf georgien
ziehe ein großer schritt für die wache
dann war es dann ernst zwischen euch
also wann habt ihr gesagt so jetzt na ja
ich liebe dich dann man denkt was will
sie von überrascht
dann hab ich also ein bisschen gedacht
bis hin zu
wir haben unsere gipfel überprüft auch
dann habe ich verstanden das okay was
ist liebe
sie liebt mich so wie ich bin dieser
soll dann sterbe ich für sie
[Musik]
mit den ängsten volk entdeckt und
einfach wunderschöne georgien und viele
kulturelle unterschied macht auch spaß
und ich merke tories hofer besucht ihre
familie in der schweiz und der usa
lernen oder pfarrer thomas dummermuth
keine wo sr technics cadu statt
es musste sie aber das ist ja eigentlich
decke oder reformiert
hin und weg